in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Jacob
and Becky are with us hey guys how are
you hi Dave
welcome welcome where're you guys from
Hudson from Michigan Wow a bit of a haul
to Nashville a little bit at least the
weather's nice this week yeah that's
good to have you guys
so you're here to do your debt-free
screen we are how much have you paid off
a hundred and forty seven thousand
dollars Wow how long did that take it
took four years but the majority has
paid off in the last ten months
whoa okay making what kind of money
during that time we started at ninety
five thousand a year and we went up to
two hundred thousand a year that's a
nice raise how did you do that we got
married oh okay
so what kind of debt is the hundred and
forty seven thousand Oh
what kind of debt isn't it that's the
real question huh there's a second
mortgage credit cards car loan line of
credit 401k loan if it had loan in the
name I had it you were just like normal
yep extremely normal so tell me your
story what happened well how the
majority the debt well I should say
pretty much all that was mine coming
into our marriage about eleven years ago
actually my first wife had had died
mm-hmm and I got some life insurance
proceeds with that mm-hmm
and then live my life that way like I
like I was would think that was my
income but it was not obviously mm-hmm
so racked up a bunch of bills got behind
on everything and then just realized one
day hey I need to do something about
this and that was about four years ago
yep okay then what happened ten months
ago well ten months ago we got married
in December of 2014
okay that's the kid goes yeah and we are
both working your plans separately but I
think we were both missing the
accountability and the encouragement and
the teamwork that we needed to really be
successful and so when we got married on
twelve thirteen fourteen and we started
attacking the debt in January and paid
it off by October yeah 2015 got in high
gear yeah and we were each used to
living off our own income and so to
basically double it we were able to
throw a lot at the debt very
we so you brought some dead end too how
much I only brought about $2,000 of a
car loan in and he brought one hundred
and forty five thousand seems fair but
you know the key was is that he was
working on cleaning it up for a long
time and the behavior had changed now if
the behavior hadn't changed it would
have been a serious issue for me mm-hmm
but he was on a track towards changing
behavior and looking towards a future of
the kids so I don't it all worked out
absolutely perfect fun fun fun so what
are your kids names in ages you've got
Micah has 13
you've got Isaac who is 10 today Oh Anna
who is 10 today tomorrow they'll be 11
okay so twins yes awesome very cool very
cool well congratulations you guys so
what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt is you know for me
the key was us being on the same page we
were working towards a common goal
together and we faithfully did the
budget every two weeks when we got paid
we did it every two weeks instead of
every month but looking ahead at the
month but doing it every two weeks the
cash spending was key before marriage I
was working your plan but I wasn't too
committed because I like to swipe my
debit card it added a level of
seriousness to it when you got married
and that's why I kicked it into
overdrive
it really did I never had to be
responsible for anyone but myself yeah
yeah I think it's a key if you're single
or on your own you even I had the kids
but I didn't have that partner so I
guess the big key is if you really want
to do this if you're not held
accountable to somebody it's gonna be
extremely difficult you need to find
another person yeah the easy part about
being single is there's nobody to tell
you what to do the bad part is there's
nobody to tell you what to do so I mean
you know I mean by holding you on your
feet to the fire
yes oh well very cool you two very well
done how's it feel it feels so good it
feels like a weight was lifted off our
shoulders when we were working through
the debt it was hard for me to spend
money you know we we do different things
like I don't want to spend X I want to
put it towards the debt it's you know
that last debt was a big a big chunk and
uh so it feels good to be free from it
we can focus on the future and
and making it a good life for us and the
kids absolutely well congratulations and
thanks for making a trip all the way
down thanks and happy birthday guys very
cool all right a hundred and forty seven
thousand dollars paid off in four months
four years most of it done in the last
ten months making ninety five to two
hundred thousand a year
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream three two one
that's how you do it right there man I
love it
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show you are not a victim you're not
a victim of big corporations you're not
a victim of Wall Street you're not a
victim of capitalism you're not a victim
of wealth inequality you're not a victim
of racism you're not a victim